In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadium for August 21st, on which we commemorate, the Holy
Marjor Vasa and her three sons, Theognos, Agapios and Pistas.
The Emperor Maximian, having published a decree ordering all his subjects to offer sacrifice
to the gods on his birthday, messengers were sent to proclaim this in all the provinces.
When the news reached Edisa in Macedonia, Pamphilius, the Pro-Consul of Helades, and Vincentinos,
Pro-Consul and Assistant in Macedonia and Thessaly, happened to be in the town to discuss the
limits of their respective jurisdictions.
They ordered that the Edict be carried out immediately, and that public sacrifice be offered
that same day to Zeus, the next day to the Son, and the other days to Hermes, Esculapios
and all the other gods.
Many fearful Christians submitted, but those who were firmly rooted in the faith resisted
heroically, among these were St. Vasa and her sons, a noble Christian of senatorial rank
who had received the faith from her parents.
She was married to a certain Valerian, an idolatrous priest, and one of the most eminent men
of the city who was the first to offer his sacrifice and libations to the idols.
Vasa then took her three sons.
The Ognius, Agapios and Pistus aside and said to them that, though their father had given
himself to the power of the demons, it was not right to imitate him, even though he
were to exercise all his paternal authority.
Remember my pains in giving birth to you, and from fear of punishment, run to Christ who is
holding his arms out to you.
For in despising the things of this world you will obtain the eternal and incorruptible
good things.
Her words had such an effect when Valerian told his sons to sacrifice the boys refused with
one voice.
He handed them over to the tribunal where Pemphilius and Vincientinos were in session.
To the magistrates' suggestions they replied that they submitted with a good will to the
laws of the empire in all that concerned its well-being and public life, but wished, however,
to follow the example of their mother's piety and that of their ancestors, keeping Christ's
commandments.
We are ready to give our bodies to torture in order to keep our souls pure and assured
before God on the day of judgment.
They declared, seized with fury, the magistrates gave Thelgnios the eldest over to torture and
had his flesh lacerated in the presence of his mother and brothers.
In the midst of his torments the saint derided the powerlessness of the pagans and declared
that, thanks to them, he would gain the more brilliant a victory.
When his bones showed through his redened flesh, his mother encouraged him, assuring him
that clothed in the panoply that Christ would give him he had nothing to fear.
And by these words, Christ's athletes showed himself inflexible and carried off the crown
of martyrdom.
They then summoned the second brother.
When the assessor asked his name, he replied, My mother, that true servant of God has named
me Agapius, and I shall strive to show myself worthy of this name, remaining faithful to the
charity Agapi of Christ.
Given over to flogging the saint scorned both the torture and the empty promises of wealth
and material advantage made by the pagans.
I want to follow in my brother's footsteps.
Having seen his endurance and torture, I now count my puny body for nothing so that I can
reveal the eternal place reserved for my soul close to God.
He was still speaking when the tyrants had his skin flayed off from his head to his chest.
He then cried out, Nothing is sweeter than to suffer for Christ and gave his soul into
God's hands.
It was then the turn of the youngest brother, Pestus, who also bravely confessed his faith,
Bistis convinced that he would show himself worthy of his name.
To the judge's arguments, he replied that even if his body belonged to them and they could
do what they wished with it, his soul was ripe and perfect, rendered resolute by the grace
of God.
They stretched him from neck to heels before dislocating his joints, and he was then beheaded
after having addressed to God a last prayer of thanksgiving.
A voice was then heard from heaven, welcoming the three young martyrs.
Her mother Bassa, having been sent to prison, pagans came to her and tried to persuade her
to submit to the imperial orders, but she did not answer them and refused the food they offered
her.
After seven days, an angel brought her heavenly food and strengthened her.
When the assistant Vincentinos had to leave for the town where he had his seat, he took
Bassa with him.
Arriving at their destination, he tried to persuade the saint to join in the sacrifice he
was about to offer, but his efforts were unsuccessful and Bassa declared to him,
"'You godless and odious man, do you think you can turn me from the path followed by
my three sons which let them carry off the trophies of victory?
I am well armed against you, as Christ has given me weapons that will overcome all your
intrigues.'
She was then plunged into a cauldron, full of water furnished at the bottom with cutting
instruments, but through the action of an angel the water overflowed, leaving the saint unhurt.
When the divine grace had also saved her from a burning furnace and from stoning she asked
Vincentinos to let her remain in the temple for a couple of hours before showing him the
futility of idols.
As soon as she went into it in the presence of all the people, the saint went straight to
the altar and by her prayer threw down the idol of Zeus which broke into a thousand fragments
as it fell to the ground.
The furious pro-concil had Bassa taken into the arena without delay to be thrown to the
wild beasts.
A tiger that they had unleashed on her came and prostrated at her feet, and when its keepers
tried to return it to its cage, it re-found all its ferocity and killed them.
The animal allowed no one to approach it, and it was only at the saint's command that
it returned quietly to its cage.
The crowd called for Bassa's release, but the hardened magistrate not being prepared to
acknowledge himself beaten by a woman ordered that she be drowned in the open sea.
More than forty study of from the coast.
When the boat drew near to the chosen place, the men charged with the execution saw the
saint, resplendent in glory.
They fell to the ground on their faces, and when they got up, Bassa, having resumed her
usual appearance, ordered them to complete their task.
Next into the waves she was received by three angelic beings who put her into a ship and
sat her on a royal throne.
After a voyage, lasting eighteen days, the saint landed on the island of Halon in the
hellispont, where she was taken to the authorities who referred her to the pro-concil of Macedonia.
In Chantinos immediately wrote to Laudiceus, the governor of the hellispont in Zizicus, urging
him to put her to death without delay for magical practices.
The governor went in person to Halon and had Bassa brought before him.
When she answered him with assurance, he asked her why she was so keen to die.
The priest's servant replied, I am in haste to be delivered from death and inherit eternal
life.
Her hands were tied behind her, and the executioners broke her limbs before finally giving her
the crown of martyrdom, by beheading her.
The priest Sofronios saw to her burial, and a church was later built in her honor on a
high place, visible from all sides by sailors who had saint Bassa as their protectress.
Through the prayers of our holy fathers, O Lord, Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us and
save us.